Charlotte what AI tools have you started
using
so I haven't used the tools that have
been rolled out as AI like chat gbt
but you know AI is in Gmail there's AI
in our phones there's AI
in pretty much everything I am using
right now is like sending me an email
about how they're enhancing the service
with AI so I although I haven't used
these new tools that have been rolled
out exclusively as ai ai is very much
already a part of our everyday life
there's Ai and social media there's Ai
and SEO whenever we type a keyword you
know the AI the algorithm is using AI to
create our search results like all these
things are already very much
Incorporated in our lives and I I have
been very slow to start using something
like Chad gbt what are your overall
thoughts on AI
all right so here's my real
is my real thought it's that I think
that these tools look incredibly amazing
like they look powerful and they look
like they could be revolutionary like I
was watching the center for Humane
technology uh on YouTube and they had
this
um they had this piece about how AI can
basically read what you're thinking like
they had somebody look at a picture of a
giraffe and then the AI read their brain
scan and spit out a picture of a giraffe
which I thought was insane because to me
this means that like people who are
non-verbal might be able to communicate
you know people who can't see maybe may
be able to see like there was a video of
somebody that they were using AI to like
help someone walk like
um they attach some uh Contraption to
their head and then it sent brains it
sent signals to their lives and they
were able to use that to walk again so I
think it has incredible birth potential
I think it can really like change the
world but I think that the stewards of
AI have not shown good faith I don't
have faith in the people who are in
charge right now
um
I just think that corporate interests
are so strong in the United States and
that we have had a philosophy of growth
at all costs for so long that it'll take
a lot to reverse that and it'll take a
lot to Steward this technology in a way
that I think is beneficial for everyone
like and I don't just mean like in our
phones and in our Gmail and things like
that I mean
seriously like because now you have ai I
mean every time you use tick tock and
you use like a face scan that's AI
That's changing like you know the way
that it can manipulate people's voices
the way it can manipulate photos and
video you know the political tension in
the United States just like the the
climate of the country makes me feel
like
AI is either going to be good or really
really bad so I think the tool itself is
helpful but I think that we have a lot
of
Bad actors in the world right now and I
and we don't have a lot of Regulation we
have corporations that are way too
powerful and
um a Congress that is super divided and
I also think of a Congress that is is
much too old to really deal with this in
the way that I think that it needs to be
dealt with
um and I just think that our country is
a little bit behind I think that we'll
we might be looking to Europe to
regulate this in a way that is
um beneficial to to the world in a way
that we probably wouldn't look to the
United States to regulate so my husband
works in privacy in in security uh
digital security
and um
he always talks about how Europe just
has such good privacy laws and um they
also you know Europe is like much much
more forceful on making corporations pay
their taxes
um so that's another thing I just think
that like the tax revenue from this
could be something that is used to
provide Universal Health Care like
there's there's just already not a lot
of social safety net in the United
States and we already don't have a
political climate of people where where
there's clearly a lot of political will
to create a more
um a more Equitable Society so I just I
just get very nervous about AI in our
hands like I just don't know if we're
uh great stewards of it at this time
well from the little I know some of the
stewards have gone to policy makers and
said we are concerned yeah it it doesn't
give me like them going to Congress to
to talk about it uh Sam Altman I think
his name is the creative open AI going
there to talk about it I'm just like
okay that's that's great that he did
that and that he's doing these hearings
and things like that but
I just think that even long before AI
you know came into the public
Consciousness there's a lot of issues
with privacy with Instagram and Facebook
as they are you know if you look back to
the election the 2016 election
um there's that film on Netflix called
um social dilemma the social dilemma
um and I think there's another film that
I can't remember the name of that
basically talks about how Facebook how
um a Corp uh uh us how a consulting firm
use the data in Facebook to help win the
election
um and and they've used the data from
Facebook to to win elections in several
countries the United States wasn't the
first one
um
I just think that uh Cambridge analytica
is the name of that company and I don't
remember the name of that actual
documentary but it was about Cambridge
analytica and so that was years before
AI was a twinkle in the Public's eye
that there are these huge
um
leaks in privacy there's like you know
shashana zuboff has the book called
um surveillance surveillance yes and and
that book talks about how these
companies have basically turned our
personal data into a commodity and how
they sell it and you know trade it and
all these other things and how our data
is the most valuable thing that they
have right now that's another reason it
brings me back to why I think our
attention is so important because every
time we scroll every time we like
something we give them data about how to
keep our attention so it's it's such a
huge industrial complex of of personal
data that the United States I think has
been very fumbly with protecting
um they're that Center for Humane
technology was showing a thing where
basically
um
there you they can use AI to like see
into your house like to do all these
things like there's just so much
potential for surveillance there's so
much potential for or like the way that
AI is like
um is used in a lot of real estate now
like whether it's like accepting
somebody's application for rental and
just like rejecting them based off of
whatever the software whatever triggers
the software whatever instead of a
one-to-one human interaction so that you
can understand where somebody's coming
from you know I think all of these
things like people having access to
housing people having privacy people
having
um
safety of people having like your
thoughts being safe from the intrusion
things like that I think there's just so
much potential
for bad I think there's a ton of
potential for good but I just don't know
if we're gonna Steward it in the way
that is best for everybody based off of
what is currently happening what has
currently happened you know the way that
our privacy has not been protected
um in the past sure and it's not always
to across the board certain communities
privacy are more invaded than others
absolutely um but aside from those and
it's not to diminish that topic of
privacy what about in terms of creatives
does it worry you does do you do you
feel that in the film and television
industry our jobs could become obsolete
or these will enhance what we do I'm not
gonna lie I am nervous about the
creative side for the same reasons
because this the creative side is
incredibly corporate
um you have these big studios that are
trying to find ways to save money trying
to find ways to balance their books
trying to find ways to
um to satisfy shareholders to raise
share prices and a lot of times
you know I don't know if this is like
exactly true but you can imagine it that
sometimes these these people at the very
top are very out of touch with the
average writer or like the average like
PA on set like they're not necessarily
thinking about oh we need to create a
writer's room for that PA to have a
career to have a way into the uh
industry and to have a way to train so
that they can eventually become
showrunners they're thinking about that
bottom line they're thinking about those
shareholders they're thinking about the
streaming Wars competition and who's
gonna come out on top who's not gonna go
away
um during this time of you know
streaming content Wars and I think a lot
of them are hugely out of touch because
I think the corporate world particularly
in the United States is extremely out of
touch with the average person and I
think that they don't based off of what
they've done the way that they've
um
tried to shut down unions the way that
they've tried to
um
how they they've basically like used
inflation as a way to like pinch money
like to take money away from the average
person these these gas companies the way
that they've raised gas prices even
though that you know what I mean like
there's so many things that these
corporations have done that show that
the bottom line is what's important to
them that it just makes me think that
again I don't know if the stewards here
are
um
trustworthy I don't know if we can
really trust them I think it's really up
to us as creatives to educate ourselves
about the actual business interests of
these people I think it's up to us to
once we educate ourselves and and
understand that we're coming into a
business that is about making money it's
not necessarily about the most creative
thing sometimes it is sometimes you know
you get wonderful projects get to be
made but a lot of times it's just about
the bottom line and it's up to us to
determine do we want to feed that do I
want to sell my idea to a place like
that or do I want to try to get it made
by myself do I want to try to find an
independent Finance saying do I want to
figure out another way like
corporate television is very much like a
regular nine to five I think
um
or it can be after you've worked in it
for a little bit of time because uh
you're answering to somebody they're
answering to somebody
and they're just trying to
make a profit ultimately which nothing
wrong with making a profit I don't think
there's I this is not about demonizing
money or making money bad in any way
because money in itself is fine and we
all need money and money is great but I
think that these corporations are just
greedy they're they're they are that is
something that we've actually seen and
that's where we are in late stage
capitalism in the United States where
we're just doing straight up profit over
everything
and it's clearly not working it's
destroying the environment it's it's
making it's taking jobs away it's making
people fear for their future we've
stripped the United States
um population of of a social safety net
we've made it so that kids can't don't
know if they can go to college or not
we've made it so that it depends on what
neighborhood you live in to know if your
kid is going to a good enough School
it's made it so that like depending on
where you live some Corporation might be
able to dump toxic waste in your
backyard and you might you know get sick
from it like we've just completely lost
the plot I think when it comes to
um profits over people and Hollywood is
no exception and I think that it's gonna
be up to us like it's up to us in the
United States for the rest of for
everything it's up to unions it's up to
Everyday People to say hey we don't want
guns in our society we don't want our
society flooded with guns we don't want
AI or we don't want tech companies to
have so much of our data we want to have
privacy we want our kids to be able to
go to good schools no matter what
neighborhood they live in we want
people to have a social safety net so
that if they get sick it doesn't matter
if they're wealthy or if they're poor
they're going to get treatment like I
think that there are just such basic
things we want housing we want people we
want people to be able to afford housing
we want pay to be uh Equitable to living
expenses like these are just basic
things that I think that the United
States is not reaching that makes me
extremely nervous to see what throwing
something like AI will do
um but I think technology is great I
think Tech I think technology can be
fantastic it can be wonderful it can
help to enhance our stories I think it's
a I think it's two sides I think it's
about the way that we move forward and I
think it's going to be up to us as
artists and creatives to speak up about
how we want this to be shepherded just
like it's up to us as a society to speak
up about how we want our country to go
forward
okay what if someone says that Darwinism
has always been a part of The Human
Experience and it's just now has a new
form which is AI and
you know the lack of affordable housing
price gouging things like that it's just
another form of Darwinism so the
survival of the fittest will win and we
just have to get on board
I think that
it is not a cogent argument I think that
it is not a one-to-one just like the
capitalism that we have in the United
States right now is not pure capitalism
you know it is neoliberal like it's like
this um late stage like crony capitalism
where
um
where corporations it's like this social
social safety net for corporations where
they don't pay any taxes the banks get
bailed out with our own tax money if you
try to bail out college students that
took out too many loans for school no
that's Darwinism but if you bail out a
bank is that Darwinism it's not right
it's like it's social socialism for
corporations it's they get to be bailed
out because they're the moneyed class
um but we don't get to be bailed out we
don't we have to like um be subject to
the rules of Darwinism into capitalism
but they don't if we if I don't do a
good business and I don't provide value
I fail but if you as a bank take risky
loans and make risky bets you get bailed
out by the government how is that the
same kind of capitalism I think that it
is just such a twisted way of looking at
the world and I think it's like this
very manipulative way of making regular
people believe that they are not
entitled build to any kind of assistance
any kind of ease
um because we're not wealthy like we
only get to really participate in we we
Darwinism only uh applies to you if
you're poor but if you're rich it
doesn't apply to you capitalism only
applies to you if you're poor but if
you're rich you get a different form of
capitalism so I think that it is a very
classist kind of way to look at things I
think it's a very like
um there's a lot of like
uh
uh hatred of the poor in America I think
I think when you look at the housing
crisis especially in California you just
see like even I was in a car talking to
an Uber driver we were passing by like a
like a homeless camp
downtown I'm in a car with Uber driver
and he's saying that these he's saying
the same thing that these people don't
want to work that these people are lazy
and all this other stuff and he's not
thinking about the fact that Los Angeles
has some of the I think a Los Angeles
has like a billion dollars in tax
revenue that it can distribute or
something like that like Los Angeles
County has some of the biggest tax
revenue in the country as a county or
something like that
um and it's also like one of the places
where it's hardest to build affordable
housing because these um landlords are
more incentivized to build uh luxury
housing because the permits you know are
more I guess acceptable it's easier to
get it because the purpose is so
expensive that it doesn't make sense to
to build something that is Affordable so
isn't that something that the government
could fix isn't that something that the
government can make permits less
expensive so that they incentivize or
that they de-incentivize people from
only building luxury housing thing like
I I just think that it's a very classist
argument and
um I think there's a disdain for the
poor in the United States that is not
going to lead us to Prosperity as a
country I think once we start letting a
few people become prosperous and
everybody else has to struggle and
suffer just for the basics
um it's it's gonna be I think
repercussions that the United States
really can't come back from because
right now we're already seeing like
population decline we're seeing like you
know countries like China
um not replacing their population the
United States people are not having
enough children there's all these fears
about whether or not we're going to have
productivity in the future at the same
time as we're talking about you know AI
taking away people's jobs what no one is
talking about though is creating a
social safety net for people in the
United States that includes health care
that includes child care that makes it
so that
um you can you can retire uh you can you
can retire there's people who are in
their old age that can't retire in the
United States this is a this is a
structural problem in the United States
other countries are not dealing with
this you know I moved to Vancouver
Canada and I've been making jokes on
stage I feel like an American Refugee
like I feel like I moved to Canada for a
better life because there's social
welfare there's social health care there
is public restrooms everywhere that are
clean that are accessible to the entire
public no matter how much money you make
there's tons of public space there's
Parks everywhere there's bike Lanes
everywhere there's trains and buses and
just all this
things that help that are conducive to
living in a good society that I think
that the United States are our
infrastructures crumbling like our
education system is being decimated by
people not wanting kids to learn from
certain books or learning about the Real
History of the United States there's
like a lot going on that I think is a
lot worse than Ai and it all has to do
with what we care about as a nation
which I think is just profit at all
costs instead of people
okay and last last point and then we'll
move on from this topic is
how much do you think the middle class
has contributed to this
I think I think that
all of us are just doing our best
honestly like I think that like people
in the middle class
first of all I'm someone my family has
gone from working class to middle class
meaning we went from I would just say we
went from having an apartment building
and renting
um renting an apartment to owning a home
my parents have owned a home for the
last 20 years and I would say that
that's what helped them get into the
middle class and my parents continue to
have to work my parents you know are not
people that are going to retire with a
ton of money
um
I think that the middle class is kind of
like I guess I would describe it as like
a moat like you have to do so much like
get into it but it definitely keeps
people out it definitely like things
like college prices home prices all
these things like
they keep people out of
these better neighborhoods these better
education systems but at the same time
it's a trap for the people that are in
it because you have to work so hard to
stay in it